c'est une petite phrase qui a mis le feu
aux poudres à bordeaux le nouveau maire
écologiste ne veut plus de sapins
publics mettront pas des arbres sur les
places de la ville notamment chez les
patients vers des souvenirs de ses pairs
me ment on faisait venir tous les jours
à plusieurs centaines de kilomètres de
bordeaux ces mots font bondir la culture
du sapin
c'est la fierté du morvan on y produit
un quart des sapins français christophe
moni fait pousser ces arbres depuis 38
ans il en vend près de 45000 par an là
je sais que ce petit enlacés la région
lyonnaise
on a noté 10 ans là bas c'est versailles
et puis on a des clients qui sont en
train de marquer là bas c'est la région
de province pour lui impensable
d'imaginer une vie économique sans cette
culture le morvan le morvan vie autour
autour du sapin au moment de noël gg 25
saisonniers est essentiellement du bras
ciné village d'à côté des gens qui
prennent leurs vacances pour venir tous
les midis on mange le restaurant du coin
ont fait on fait vivre les restaurants
ont fait vivre les boulangeries ont fait
vivre toute l'économie locale
alors faut-il mettre les sapins aux
revues dans les rues d'auxerre les avis
sont partagés soir était alors qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire du plastique partout
c'est pas mieux comme ça ça protège la
nature s'est découpé des sapins qu'on
m'a jeté après mais après noël c'est
festif des sapins des fleurs cesse des
racines ça scout pour faire les maisons
en bois on les coupe assez dérange que
personne face à la contestation
le maire de bordeaux pierre hurni
envisage désormais une consultation
locale
[Musique]